[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serin schönen Freitagabend Ihnen
alle Kristin sagt wie geht es der
deutschen Fußballnationalmannschaft ich
würde sagen alle in Aufbruchstimmung gut
so hallo und guten Abend dann blicken
wir mal auf die Themen der heutigen
Sendung
kein Verständnis für diesen klimaprotest
quer durch die Parteien Hager des
scharfe Kritik an der Blockade des
Berliner Flughafens
schnellerer Weg zum deutschen Pass
Innenministerin Fräser will
Einbürgerungen deutlich erleichtern
Putin umwirbt die Mütter der russische
Präsident versichert bei einem Treffen
seinen Mitgefühl andere Mütter
demonstrieren gegen den Krieg
[Musik]
es war der jüngste Aufreger der
klimaaktivisten der sogenannten letzten
Generation sie schafften es gestern aufs
Rollfeld des Hauptstadtflughafens
klebten sich dort fest und legten den
Flugbetrieb für anderthalb Stunden lang
immer mehr Menschen finden diese
Aktionen wenig hilfreich oder sind
schwer genervt und fordern härtere
Konsequenzen und dazu zählen auch immer
mehr Politiker Christian hübscher
berichtet über den Protest und die
Reaktionen
sie zerschneiden den Maschendrahtzaun
und gelangen aufs Rollfeld sechs
Aktivisten die sich selbst als letzte
Generation bezeichnen kleben sich auf
Start und Landebahnen Fest der
Flugverkehr am BER muss gestoppt werden
für anderthalb Stunden geht gar nichts
mehr bis zu 4000 Passagiere sind
betroffen das alles um Aufmerksamkeit
für den Klimawandel zu bekommen am Tag
danach verschärft die Politik den Ton
das ist keine Form von legitimen Protest
ich will das eindeutig sagen ist ein
gefährlicher Eingriff in den Flugverkehr
gefährdet Menschen und deswegen ist es
auch nicht in Ordnung und muss in einem
Rechtsstaat dann auch bestraft werden
über Strafen für solche Proteste
entscheiden Gerichte so
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann aber auch
er lässt Wissen eindringen auf das
Rollfeld eines Flughafens kann wegen
eines gefährlichen Eingriffs in den
Luftverkehr strafbar sein seit Monaten
kommt es zu Stör Aktionen
klimaaktivisten behindern den Verkehr
bewerfen Kunstwerke mit Suppen kartoff
sammelbrei und Farbe inzwischen nimmt
selbst bei der klimaschutzpartei den
Grünen das Verständnis dafür ab mein
Ratschlag an diese jungen Menschen
bringt eure Energie ein dass ihr helft
dass wir mehr Klimaschutz durchsitzen
helft nicht den Gegnern des
Klimaschutzes diese Maßnahmen sind
Wasser auf die Mühlen von denjenigen die
gegenklimaschutz sind einer der sechs
klimaaktivisten muss weiter in Gewahrsam
bleiben die anderen sind inzwischen
wieder auf freiem Fuß das
Landeskriminalamt ermittelt gegen sie
seit Jahren streitet die EU über die
Verteilung von geflüchteten und
illegale Migration heute gab es dazu ein
Krisentreffen der Innenminister in
Brüssel besonders Rom macht gerade Druck
und fordert mehr Solidarität bei der
Verteilung von Bootsflüchtlingen deren
Zahl sei dieses Jahr in Italien und mehr
als 50% gestiegen eine Einigung in dem
Streit war auch heute nicht in Sicht
und wir bleiben bei Migration nach
Deutschland zugewanderte sollen bald
schneller und einfacher den deutschen
Pass erhalten können das sieht ein
Gesetzentwurf des
Bundesinnenministeriums vor statistisch
gesehen lässt sich bislang nur etwa
einer von 100 in Deutschland lebenden
Ausländern pro Jahr einbürgern mehr zur
Reform die Teil des Koalitionsvertrages
ist und so Kritik daran von Nicole
Dietmann
bundesinnenministerin ferser heute beim
Technischen Hilfswerk im
niedersächsischen Emden im Mittelpunkt
hier allerdings ihre Pläne für eine
einfachere Einbürgerung es geht vor
allem darum die Lebensrealität
abzuwünden wir sind ein vielfältiges
modernes Einwanderungsland und ich finde
das Gesetzgebung das auch nachvollziehen
muss und man ein anderes Verständnis
dafür entwickelt die Pläne im
Wesentlichen die einbürgerungsfrist soll
sinken von bisher acht auf fünf Jahre
Migranten sein ihre bisherige
Staatsbürgerschaft nicht mehr aufgeben
müssen und außerdem sollen die älteren
unter ihnen keinen Sprachnachweis
bringen müssen sondern lediglich in der
Lage sein sich mündlich mitzuteilen
die Union lehnt die Pläne ab vor allem
eine Absenkung der einbürgerungsfrist
das ist natürlich ein gewaltiger
Unterschied weil die Zeit in der sie
hier leben sind natürlich auch Teil der
Gesellschaft sind und
Integrationsmaßnahmen
integrationsvorgänge stattfinden
insofern ist es schon ein gewaltiger
Unterschied fünf Jahre sind eben eine
sehr sehr kurze Zeit die AFD wird unter
anderem wegen ihrer Äußerungen über
Migranten und Flüchtlinge vom
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet sie hält
die gesamte Debatte für falsch und lässt
auch das Argument Fachkräftemangel nicht
gelten 2,2 Millionen junge Menschen
zwischen 20 und 34 Jahren haben in
Deutschland wieder ein Studium noch ein
Berufsabschluss also hier muss
eingesetzt werden wir müssen uns erstmal
um die eigene Bevölkerung kümmern und
das heißt die Bildungschancen verbessern
und weiter in Bildung investieren
Beifall hingegen aus der Linkspartei sie
hält die Pläne für einen Booster für den
Arbeitsmarkt wir werden als Freistaat
Thüringen in Vietnam in der Mongolei in
Handarbeit Schein in der Ukraine junge
Leute an um bei uns Ausbildung zu machen
den Arbeitsmarkt öffnen Leistungen
anerkennen Zuwanderer zu einem
Bekenntnis motivieren die Ampel will
Deutschland zu einem modernen
Einwanderungsland machen und geht damit
einen weiteren Punkt aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag an
das Kabinett hat die geplante befristete
Deckelung der Preise für gasfernwärme
und Strom auf den Weg gebracht von der
Preisbremse profitieren Haushalte und
Unternehmen sie umfasst 80% des
bisherigen Verbrauchs für Mengen darüber
hinaus gilt der höhere Marktpreis
umgesetzt wird der preisdeckel im März
gilt dann aber auch rückwirkend für
Januar und Februar viele wichtige
Entscheidungen heute im Bundesrat so hat
die Länderkammer beschlossen die drei
letzten Atomkraftwerke bis Mitte April
am Netz zu lassen und die Vermieter
müssen die CO2-Abgabe künftig
mitbezahlen die wird fällig wenn
Wohnungen mit Gas oder Öl geheizt werden
außerdem kann die Reform des Wohngeldes
anfangen nächsten Jahres in Kraft treten
bisher haben etwa 600.000 Haushalte
Anspruch auf Wohngeld künftig sollen es
2 Millionen sein auch der
durchschnittliche Betrag steigt von 177
Euro im Monat auf etwa 3
und auch darauf hat der Bundesrat den
Deckel gemacht das Bürgergeld kommt zum
1 Januar und ersetzt damit Hartz IV hier
sind die wesentlichen Punkte
bürgergeldbezieher bekommen ab Januar
mehr Geld sie sollen besser als bisher
für eine dauerhafte Arbeit qualifiziert
werden
dass umstrittene Schonvermögen wird
erhöht 40.000 Euro darf der eigentliche
Leistungsbezieher zunächst behalten
Sanktionen greifen weiterhin sofort
Christoph testerell mit den
Hintergründen
es geht um die Menschen die ihre
Schicksale ungern in die Kamera erzählen
gut zwei Drittel aller
Langzeitarbeitslosen sind ohne
Ausbildung mehr als die Hälfte haben
massive psychische Probleme oder andere
gesundheitliche Einschränkungen viele
kämpfen mit Drogensucht Schulden oder
Kriegstraumata
ihnen stabil ins Arbeitsleben
zurückverhelfen das soll das neue
Bürgergeld wobei der jüngste Streit
unter Politikern um Sanktionen oder
Schonvermögen am Kern der Sache
vorbeigehe findet die die im Jobcenter
den Betroffenen gegenüber sitzt die
Menschen haben zum Teil so viele
Probleme und Sorgen da muss erstmal der
Kopf und das Herz frei sein um sich dann
anderen Themen wie Ausbildung wie
Weiterbildung und wie auch der Arbeit
zuzuwenden im Prinzip sei der neue
Ansatz gut meint die Chefin des
Jobcenters mehr und besser weiterbilden
damit Betroffene tatsächlich zurück in
die Spur finden nur ob es klappt müsste
sich noch zeigen drei Jahre Umlernen für
Langzeitarbeitslose das schaffe nicht
jeder und Beobachter des Arbeitsmarktes
geben zu bedenken dass mit der
Weiterbildung Klappe nur wenn auch
anders wonach gebessert werde nicht
allein beim Bürgergeld es muss ergänzt
werden um entsprechende
Weiterbildungsangebote so dass die
Menschen sich dann auch entsprechend
weiterentwickeln können ihre Kompetenzen
ihre Fähigkeiten aufbauen und ausbauen
und dann auch wirklich gut in den
Arbeitsmarkt in neue Beschäftigung
hineinzukommen anders gesagt dem
Betroffenen Lust auf Ausbildung machen
das funktioniert nur wenn der Staat
Ihnen die passende Weiterbildung auch
wirklich bieten kann da liegt derzeit
noch einiges im Argen grundsätzlich aber
begrüßen viele Ökonomen das Bürgergeld
wir wissen die große Mehrzahl der
Betroffenen möchte Arbeit nicht nur um
gutes Einkommen zu haben sondern auch
wieder Respekt zu bekommen eine Teilhabe
zu haben daher ist diese Reform eine
große Chance und für manche eine neue
Chance nach vielen Jahren im
gesellschaftlichen aus
Matthias vornauf ist jetzt bei mir hallo
Matthias hallo guten Abend im aktuellen
ZDF Politbarometer wurde das Bürgergeld
auch abgefragt mit welchem Ergebnis aber
wir sehen da ein klares Meinungsbild für
die weiter bestehenden strengen
Sanktionen
74% sagen das ist gut so 21 Prozent
lehnen es ab Mehrheiten aller Parteien
Anhänger sprechen sich für diese
Sanktionen aus auch bei sPD Linke und
Grünen
das der Regelsatz zum Jahreswechsel um
53 Euro steigt findet fast die Hälfte
gut so und ein Viertel zu wenig viel
Verständnis also wohl auch weil der
Preisdruck vielen weh tut
die hohen Preise sind für mich ein
großes Problem das Sagen 55 Prozent und
mehr als zwei Drittel sparen zu Hause
stark am Energieverbrauch
die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft Matthias
steht aktuell stark in der Kritik
Stichwort Diversität auch Menschenrechte
wie wird das gesehen na die Kritik an
Katar ist übertrieben das sagen nur 14
Prozent 49 Prozent sagen die Kritik
wegen Menschenrechtsverletzungen müsste
härter ausfallen
31% finden es richtig so wie es ist
und was erwarten die deutschen sportlich
vom Nationalteam
nur 6 Prozent glauben dass Deutschland
Weltmeister wird 77 Prozent glauben das
nicht
mit einem Sieg gegen Spanien am Sonntag
könnte sich das allerdings etwas ändern
6 oder 77% wozu gehören 77 bin ich auch
da danke schön Matthias vorne und das
gesamte ZDF Politbarometer ab 22 Uhr im
heute-journal oder jederzeit in unserer
heute App wir machen weiter mit einer
wirtschaftsnachricht die deutsche
Wirtschaft behauptet sich überraschend
gut trotz rekordination und
Lieferengpässen das Bruttoinlandsprodukt
stieg zwischen Juli und September um
0,4% gegenüber dem vor Quartal das Teil
der Statistische Bundesamt mit und damit
etwas mehr als erwartet vor allem
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
kurbelten mit ihren Ausgaben das
Wirtschaftswachstum an
die Ukraine braucht internationale Hilfe
um das Land trotz ständiger russischer
Angriffe mit Energie versorgen zu können
Außenministerin baerbock hat dazu ein
g7-treffen einberufen es soll auch darum
gehen wie ukrainische Städte besser
gegen Luftangriffe geschützt werden
können denn der Beschuss geht immer
weiter im wieder eroberten Person etwa
dort haben russische Raketen nach
ukrainischen Angaben mehrere Gebäude
getroffen dabei sein heute 15 Menschen
getötet und 35 verletzt worden
in diesem Krieg sind bislang auch viele
tausende russische Soldaten gestorben
der Protest Betroffener Ehefrauen und
Mütter wird vom russischen Apparat
gefürchtet und daher verboten vor dem
russischen Muttertag am Sonntag sucht
russlands Präsident medienwirksam die
Nähe der Frauen Alexandra vakano
ihre Söhne sind in den Krieg gezogen die
Mütter extra vom Kreml ausgewählt heute
sitzen sie bei Kaffee und Gebäck mit dem
zusammen der den Angriff auf die Ukraine
gestartet hat das inszenierte treffen
live im russischen Fernsehen für eine
Mutter ist ihr Sohn egal wie alt er ist
immer ein Junge sagt Putin von den
Soldaten Müttern kein kritisches Wort
zum Krieg außerhalb der kreml-mauern
schon Kritik das sei eine weitere
putinvorstellung gewesen heißt es von
einer verbotenen Vereinigung der Mütter
und Ehefrauen diese Frauen waren von der
Volksfront waren Abgeordnete das war ein
Treffen das vereinbart wurde aber das
war wieder ein Dialog unter sich die
Volksfront wird Putin angeführt
verrostete Sturmgewehre alte russische
Panzer die Soldaten sind schlecht
ausgestattet beklagen viele Frauen und
Mütter warum gibt es keine richtige
militärische Ausbildung keine richtige
technische Ausstattung sie sagen es ist
an der Zeit zu handeln nicht zu denken
und nicht darauf zu warten dass alle in
diesem verdammten Fleischwolf zerlegt
werden die Stimme der Soldatenmütter in
früheren Kriegen einst eine lautere
Stimme
und Test und Oppositionen sind in
Russland seit dem Februar 2022 viel
schwieriger sind mit sehr viel höheren
Repressionen verbunden so dass wir hier
nicht davon ausgehen können dass es hier
zu großen Protesten jetzt erstmal kommen
diese Mütter und Frauen haben ihre
Kinder und Ehemänner verloren der
russische general drückt sein Beileid so
aus
meine Mutter sagte diesen wundervollen
Satz von heute an gehörst du nicht zu
mir du gehörst dem Land der Heimat
die Soldatenmütter auch gleich Thema bei
ZDF heute live um 19.30 zu Gast
Politikberater und Russland Experte Nico
lange mit diskutieren möglich wie immer
in der ZDF heute App
jetzt kommen wir vom Verkehr in der Luft
zum Verkehr am Boden wie zufrieden sind
die Deutschen mit der Mobilität am
eigenen Wohnort das hat unter anderem
der Bund erfragt und demnach sind ein
Drittel der Bürger unzufrieden mit der
Erreichbarkeit von Bus und Bahn der
größte Verbesserungsbedarf liegt laut
Umfrage bei der Taktung und nur knapp
die Hälfte der Bürger sind mit der
Sicherheit der Radwege zufrieden
seine Stimme hatte Gewicht Hans Magnus
Enzensberger war einer der
einflussreichsten deutschen
Intellektuellen im Alter von 93 Jahren
ist der in München gestorben er war
sprach Zauberer politischer Denker und
Publizist viele seiner Werke
literarische Paukenschläge der jungen
Bundesrepublik seine Zeitschrift
Kursbuch wurde zum kult-magazin der
Studentenbewegung Manfred Ahlers
erinnert bei den Studentenprotesten in
den 60er Jahren ist Hans Markus
Enzensberger als einer der Wortführer
dabei aber vor einen ideologischen
krachen der Linken lässt sich der
Freigeist nicht spannen gereicht
ich war einfach nicht zuverlässig er
wird 1929 in Kaufbeuren geboren kommt
als Sohn eines höheren Postbeamten aus
bürgerlichen Verhältnissen nach einem
literatur- und Philosophiestudium wird
Enzensberger ein prominenter Lyriker in
der sogenannten Gruppe 47 entwickelt er
mit Ingeborg Bachmann Günter Grass
Marcel Reich-Ranicki und vielen anderen
die neue deutsche Literatur viele sehen
Enzensberger als eine der wichtigsten
deutschen Lyriker immer kritisch sich
immer am Zeitgeist reibend noch mit 83
Jahren kritisierte er mit harschen
Worten die europäischen Institutionen in
Brüssel bezeichnete sie als sanfte
Monster
ob wir eine Glühbirne reinschrauben
dürfen welches Obst wir essen dürfen und
Brett also müssen sich eigentlich alles
ein er war einer der bekanntesten und
vielleicht scharfsinnigsten Lyriker der
deutschen Nachkriegsgeschichte
umstritten aber vielfach geehrt und
ausgezeichnet und vor allem immer
realistisch
[Applaus]
am Sonntag zählt für die deutsche
Mannschaft nur ein Sieg gegen Spanien
mehr Druck geht gar nicht was für eine
Bürde aber die Stimme sich ganz gut ein
wir haben die Qualität zu gewinnen
selbstbewusste Worte des Bundestrainers
und zugleich Ansporn um den Pflicht sie
gegen Spanien einzufahren eine jetzt
erst recht Mentalität ist Sonntagabend
ein Muss und das erste offizielle
Mannschaftstraining nach der
japan-niederlage heute Nachmittag ist
gezeichnet von großem Ernst und das
entspricht der durchaus auch der Lage
der Fußballnation jetzt kommt's einfach
drauf an dass wir dass wir zusammen
ja das Spiel am Sonntag angehen und alle
Gas geben Gas geben und damit den Trend
umkehren denn seit der WM 2018 hat die
deutsche Mannschaft von acht
Turnierspielen nur zwei gewonnen
mithelfen und das ist eine gute
Nachricht kann nach überstandenen
Knieproblemen wohl wieder Leroy sané der
letzte Sieg gegen Spanien an einem
Pflichtspiel gelangt übrigens 1988 dank
Rudi Völler damals noch mit Löwenmähne
ja lange her gute Nachricht für deutsche
Fans sie dürfen im Stadion nun doch
Regenbogen Symbole tragen Sven Voss in
Katar aber für die deutsche Mannschaft
steht jetzt dass wir gegen Spanien im
Fokus
ja und dieses Spiel gegen Spanien findet
ihr hinter mir im albate Stadion statt
eine halbe Stunde vom deutschen Quartier
entfernt quasi Heimspiel für die
deutsche Mannschaft kai havertz hat
heute noch zu mir gesagt und mir
versichert dass die deutsche Mannschaft
auf dieses Spiel brennt und dass sie den
Turnaround bei dieser WM auf jeden Fall
noch schaffen will und dass sie auf der
auf die Unterstützung der deutschen Fans
in Deutschland hofft Deutschland gegen
Spanien das ist nicht nur das Spiel des
Jahres das ist ein wegweisendes Duell
für den deutschen Fußball und live im
ZDF danke schön Sven nach Kata die
Niederlande haben es verpasst als erstes
Team ins Achtelfinale einzuziehen durch
das eins zu eins gegen Ecuador und
Gastgeber Katar ist als erste Mannschaft
ausgeschieden 1:3 im Duell des
asienmeisters gegen den Afrika Meister
seniger erstmalig kommt in der WM
Geschichte für ein Austragungsland so
früh das Turnier aus
überaus emotional der zweite Auftritt
des Iran sportlich durch den
beeindruckenden Last Minute Sieg gegen
Wales und politisch erneut bewegend aber
anders als zum Auftakt
diesmal singen die Spiele mit leise vor
vier Tagen gegen England schwieg das
Team Iran zur Nationalhymne für
regimekritische Fans ist die Sache klar
beim ersten Spiel haben sie nicht
gesungen dieses Mal waren sie gezwungen
ihre Lippen ein wenig zu bewegen sie
müssen sich unter Druck gesetzt gefühlt
haben dies zu tun das ist Politik wir
sind hier um den Fußball zu genießen im
Spiel überschlagen sich in der
Schlussphase die Ereignisse rot für
Wales Torwart Hennessy Iran nutzt die
Überzahl in der 8 Minute der
Nachspielzeit usb-tech me und 3 Minuten
später Ramin reser Jahren zum 2:0 Sieg
für ihre an gegen Wales
ja und am Abend kann England als zweites
Team ins Achtelfinale einziehen dann
vielen Dank Christin nach etwas Regen
kommt das Wochenende teils trübt teils
sonnig aber meist trocken daher mehr
dann gleich von Katja horneffer das
heute journal um 22 Uhr mit Maria das
lomka das war die Nachrichtenlage am
Freitag bis morgen und vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen
[Musik]
guten Abend auf diesem Satellitenbild
von gestern sehen sie sehr schön diesen
wolkenwirbel über Großbritannien dieses
Tief wollte eigentlich nach Osten
weiterziehen aber das gelingt nicht und
das liegt an dem Hoch Erik das hält
dagegen und deswegen konnte das Tief
nichts anderes machen als nach Norden
ausweichen sein Wolkenband hier sein
Regenband wurde in die Länge gezogen
auch heute Nacht fällt noch Regen
zwischen der Ostseeküste und dem
Alpenrand und dort reicht vielleicht
auch noch mal für Schneeregen im Westen
ist es trocken zum Teil auch klar bei
West Südwestwind die Temperaturen in
dieser Nacht sinken auf sechs Grad an
der Nordsee bis auf ein Grad an der
Mosel oder auch am alten Rand und morgen
erwarten uns dann Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 5 Grad in der Oberpfalz und
maximal 11 Grad am Rhein auch morgen
Vormittag kann es in Ost Sachsen oder
auch in Niederbayern noch etwas regnen
sonst wird das ein ganz freundlicher
November Sonnabend auch mal mit
Sonnenschein am ehesten am Rhein auch
hier Richtung Nordseeküste am Sonntag
erwarten wir dann durchaus Nebel zum
Teil aber auch strahlenden Sonnenschein
besonders am Alpenrand bei Temperaturen
von vier bis zehn Grad am späten
Nachmittag kommen dann von Nordwesten
neue Regenwolken heran bis bald